well right now this is kind of where the
hot spot is in terms of the flooding so
it started
all the way in the south really near
that belgium uh border
and the water has risen up and right now
here in vendo and
this is kind of the area where it's most
serious at the moment
i'm also at a red cross location that is
different from where our coordination
center
for all of these red cross activities
was before so even we've had to evacuate
to a different location
because water is rising and we want to
make sure that
at least um you know none of us are
affected by flooding and we can continue
to provide assistance
so where are you going to and how many
people have you had to evacuate
well it's the local authorities who are
in charge of the evacuations and what we
do as the red cross is we support
wherever we can
so if that means like yesterday night we
heard that a
hospital in the region had to be
evacuated he sent over some of our
ambulances to help
with that evacuation um earlier in the
week
we saw that all the way in the south
there were people in a nursing home that
had been there overnight
um stranded on the second floor they had
no contact with the outside world
so the military had to go and get them
out of that situation and then we were
able to provide them with
temporary shelter for the night bring
them to hotels
make sure they're okay not just
physically but also mentally
obviously it's very challenging if
you're stuck for hours
somewhere where there's no electricity
you have no contact with the outside
world
all you know is that there's water
outside and there's no place for you to
go
they had to evacuate an entire hospital
yes they did that out of precaution
because it's close to a river
and at first we were afraid that that
river might have already overflowed last
night
thankfully it did not but all of those
patients have been
relocated to different hospitals all
over the country
and now we're keeping a close eye to
monitor whether that not
you have the available that you need one
would assume that in this sort of a
situation
water drinkable drinking water and food
are going to be an issue yeah so at the
moment we do have the supplies that we
need but there were some areas earlier
in the week where there were small areas
that were cut off from
any supplies so that was the first
priority getting people out of those
situations
so that they were brought to a safe
place but a lot of them
thankfully have already been able to go
back to their homes but this is really
when
um you know the rebuilding starts
because those homes have been flooded
maybe
cars have been uh damaged there's damage
in the homes
so you know they're all the way in the
south they're already
going back to their homes and seeing
what they can do to repair and now we're
moving further up north to make sure
that all of the people
here are at least in physical safety
making sure that they have
shelter that they have food and water
for the night and then hopefully bring
them back to their homes as soon as they
can
and then we have to see what the next
steps are it's it's interesting because
often when we speak
to people from um humanitarian
organizations
who are experiencing things like this is
often in the geographical south
um have you ever in your
career experienced anything like this
before
no i have not obviously the netherlands
is a country that's um
below sea level so we do we are very
used to dealing with butter we have
um systems like um dikes we have systems
around the ocean that kind of prevent
floods from coming in
the really big one was in the previous
century in 1953
the great flood but um in this area in
the south they have experienced flooding
in the 80s and the 90s as well and i've
spoken to some people over the last few
days that are a little bit older
that said you know i was there for those
floods and
they were bad but i've never seen
anything like this in my life
one would assume that they're going to
be a lot of displaced people there
yeah so we did help to evacuate a bunch
of people i spoke to some people earlier
that were evacuated from that
nursing home that i mentioned earlier
they said we're not going to be able to
go home for a few weeks
um you know they were kind of getting
their bearings after they've been
evacuated and
slept on camp beds for the night and
they said okay well we're just happy
we're safe but what happens now
um so most of them have been placed in
hotels for now
um obviously this is also a tourist area
and a lot of the tourists have
either not come or had to come home had
to go home uh so thankfully there are a
lot of spaces there and where where
there aren't we're setting up emergency
shelter
making sure there are camp beds there
are blankets that people have
toiletries water and food um and then
you know as soon as the water sort of
goes back down
um that's where we can start looking at
how soon people can go back home
how how are you looking at this i mean
how soon do you think once those flood
waters recede people are going to be
able to get back
into their homes are you looking at long
term having to look after
these displaced people well what we're
hoping at the moment is that it won't be
that long because what we've already
seen all the way in the south
is that there are a lot of people that
have been able to go home
um so obviously we're hoping that that
can happen as soon as possible but the
thing with water is that it can be very
unpredictable
so we have to continue to monitor the
situation and
see what happens when that water travels
further towards the north
and the west of the country is it still
going to be very high and are we going
to have issues there
or is that water going to have some
place to go in which case you can start
focusing on relocating
the people in the southern area of the
country are you also concerned that
there's more
rain forecast for the weekend naomi
well that's also something that we are
continuing to monitor but at the moment
outside it's sunny it's dry so that's a
good sign
um but that water needs a place to go
and what we're seeing is that
especially in the more urbanized areas
um
getting rid of the water hasn't been the
priority the priority has has been to
get people out and bring them to safety
so if that water stays there and we do
get more rain later in the week
then that could worsen the situation but
obviously we are
hopeful that that's not going to happen